and so yes i'm not saying you know
i'm not saying but i'm just saying hello
everybody my name is nyan i'm the black
female engineer i provide content for
you and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about how to get
your first six-figure job as a software
engineer and may i say happy 2020 to
y'all because oh my goodness i am
feeling
quite fantastic quite phenomenal i am
very energized and just so so ready for
turning 22 to be the year of change of
getting it of just working as hard as i
can to set up the rest of my life and i
know that sounds
like a lot but to be honest how i feel
and if that's how you feel too then you
are at the right place now huge huge
thank you to flatiron school for
sponsoring this video flatter school
many of you already know was the cutting
boot camp i attended in the summer of
2020 and so we're going to dive into
that a little later in the video but
first let's talk about how to get that
coin in 2022 so let's get into it number
one first thing you need to do so that
you get that six figure offer is make
sure you are learning in demand coding
languages now for 2022 according to
berkeley university the three most in
demand languages will be javascript java
and python so
if you are starting to learn how to code
now try to steer towards these three
languages and actually had searched
toward python and javascript when i was
first learning and
well look at us now oh yes make sure you
are learning the most in demand
languages because you want to make sure
that when your resume gets to the doors
of these hiring managers that they see
okay so they are well versed and up to
date with languages that we need the
most and so like come on over here so
yes make sure you're learning the most
in demand language number two make sure
you're packing your resume with
transferable skills and projects
whatever roles or experience
you have or you have obtained in the
past see how you can make it work to
show how that would make you a fantastic
software engineer and so when you think
okay so let's say i've been a barista
for the last five years and you may
think okay well this has nothing to do
with software engineering and you know
it's just not gonna work for me like no
you are wrong and i'm gonna show you why
so you've been a barista that likely
means that you are fantastic at
communicating with others both customers
and higher ups like managers and whatnot
one you also are likely really great at
handling multiple tasks at one time two
on top of that i would bet you are
fantastic at handling yourself in high
pressure situations
three right there i just gave you three
skills to highlight on your resume to
show employers why you would be a
fantastic software engineer and the
reason this is important is because a
lot of employers will look at your
resume and your past experience when
trying to figure out what type of offer
package to give you and so we don't want
them to think oh so they have no you
know previous experience and so let's
give them this low ball offer and call
it a day you want to show them like yo i
know i'm new to this field of software
engineering but i have a ton of skill
that i will be using in this job to make
me a great great software engineer and
so that is why you want to do that now
going to the project side projects are a
fantastic way to show that you are well
versed in a language or technology now
what if you're thinking okay well that's
great naya but how am i even gonna do
this project like i can't even print
hello world on the terminal like
how about you get there well that is
where our amazing sponsors flat out of
school comes in flatter school is a
coding bootcamp that really wants to
make sure that you develop all the
skills necessary to make sure that you
come out a desirable hire and that
includes through the making and building
of projects like i said i went to
florida school and i came out having
built four projects all of which i had
put on my resume and i actually didn't
make any other projects other than the
ones i built in flatiron school because
they were in my opinion fantastic
because slanted school equipped me with
the tools necessary to build these
amazing projects to show to employers
and so definitely don't let another year
go by where you're doing just the same
old thing and just
coasting through life i mean if you want
if that's what you desire in life and
love and everything then sure but i'm
thinking you clicked on this video
because you actually like me 1 2022 to
be the year of change where you are
setting up everything you need for your
future and the thing is i'm talking
about like for your future but with
planner school you're actually able to
go from barista to software engineer in
as little as 15 weeks
yeah yeah that was the case for me i
started june i want to say 22nd of 2020
and i finished my bootcamp october 2nd
of 2020 and that was actually the day i
got my first ever job offer
so like come on y'all like at the end of
the 15 weeks you still have
most of 2022 left to live your life in
everything and so to me that sounds like
an amazing deal so let's say you do love
the idea of working in tech but software
engineering isn't for you that is
completely fine because fires school
actually offers three other courses to
pick from from data scientists to cyber
security to product design and so when
you think about all of that i don't know
to me there's
not much of an excuse to not at least
try and if you do want to at least try
flatter school also is allowing you all
if you click on the link below to try
multiple lessons for free free free free
now you're able to dabble in these
different courses and see which one
resonates most with you because at the
end of the day this is your life so you
want to make sure that you actually are
going to be enjoying what you're
learning in flat iron school and this is
the perfect opportunity to do so and if
you apply today with the link in the
description box below by may you can be
calling yourself an employed software
engineer isn't that insane like
to me that's insane uh that's that's
insane and so yes make sure the 2022 is
the year of you the year of change the
year of doing everything you need to do
to make sure that you are waking up just
so
happy and in love with your life and
your work and your day to day your
monday well maybe not money i'm not i'm
not too in love my monday um but her and
i are acquaintances now anyway back to
the whole subject so find a day with the
link in my description box below and see
what all can happen in 2022 so now let's
go to number three just now that was
transferable skills and projects number
three
think about location location location
location so when you think about the
offers people get for different roles in
general it does not come as a shock to
many of us that bigger cities offer
larger
salaries and pay than smaller ones side
by side comparison here according to
indeed.com if you get a job as a
software engineer in new york city your
salary would likely come out to a little
over 125
1000 oh my goodness that's just so much
money so 125 000 it was about 126
actually but if you get the exact same
role in oklahoma your salary comes out
to a little over 75 000
that's insane that's wild that's fifty
thousand dollars right
yes wow i was a finance major fifty
thousand dollars right off the bat
simply because of location and so you
definitely wanna consider what specific
locations you're applying to when you
are applying for your roles now i know
i know
many of you will be saying hey knives
girl um
it costs way more money to live in
manhattan new york than it does oklahoma
you're correct you you you got me you
are correct however one thing about
these last two
two years is we have seen that we are
able to do our work
most most of the time from anywhere
especially a tech job and so when we
consider the idea of being able to
work from home or work anywhere in the
country but being paid this big city
salary then we're like okay or i'm i
keep saying we me i'm like okay yeah
maybe
applying to jobs in new york city is the
uh is the move and i'm actually speaking
from experience my job i actually had
the ability to work pretty much anywhere
in the country i chose la because i'm 23
and wanted
the lifestyle but the cost of living and
everything i definitely feel it more
than i would in albuquerque and so
so think about that and remember that
when you are job hunting and make sure
that those are questions you ask because
top fortune 50 companies are allowing
their employees to work from home
forever forever forever forever forever
forever and so yeah definitely ask about
that in your interviews and say okay so
yeah i'm applying for this job based in
san francisco can i go up here in
nebraska and call it a day with the
salary definitely don't ask it like that
but yes definitely ask those questions
because some companies you get the
salary without getting that pain and
hurt of a huge huge cost of living and
number four lastly but definitely
definitely definitely not least is you
want to make sure you are networking
network not only because that cements
your odds of getting the role of being
picked and chosen for this new job of
yours but through the relationships you
build networking one of the questions
you may ask is how much can i expect to
earn at so and so company
my door just opened that was pretty
creepy that was that was pretty creepy
the door just like swung open
so anyway through these relationships
you build one of the questions you may
feel compelled and
comfortable asking is hey
how much can i expect to earn at
so-and-so company for this role either
maybe the person actually works at that
company that you are currently in the
recruitment process for
or they know of a person or they just
know the industry but after a certain
time of being in this
in this field and talking to different
people you know the industry and so you
just kind of know certain things about
things like pay and so definitely ask
those questions because by asking and
seeing what to expect it can definitely
increase your confidence for going into
negotiations if you know that the
average is actually around 130 for this
company and they come to you with 98 you
can say hey may i pretty please get that
hundred thirty and so make sure that
throughout your learning process not
even when you start the job hunt but
throughout your learning process
throughout your job hunt and active
interviewing make sure you are building
these relationships with other
individuals and ask these types of
questions because truly truly they can
make all the difference there we go
everybody my tips for how to get that
six figure offer without even a computer
science degree again make sure you check
out the link in my description box and
apply to flatiron today because again if
you start today in as little as 15 weeks
you can look back at this video and be
like wow
wow i really did that here i am now pen
in hand about to sign my six figure
offer and it all just took
watching a youtube video for how exactly
i can get here but hopefully you have a
great day and yeah i will speak to you
all very very soon so no thank you bye